i always stay grounded to the fact that
i gotta worry about the next video am i
gonna make this video better than my
last i try to just keep focus on that
and that kind of keeps the
bigger picture almost small for me
[Music]
i'm chris lamberson i'm 25 years old and
i play video games
so i started getting into gaming when i
was around 16 or 17. my friends
introduced me to call of duty we had
just went on back and forth on scene who
had a better kd justine who's better at
the game and it got to a point where i
became better than all my friends and i
wanted to see how good everyone else was
in the world so i started posting my
content online did about 2000 videos and
then wars when i came out that's when i
started really just competing in
different tournaments i played
basketball when i was younger and so
that kind of competitive drive kind of
came over into gaming and that's how i
kind of like love competing
so i had been doing video games for
about three years while still going to
school and still playing basketball but
it was never really a career at the time
so it got to a point where i was making
pretty good money and i wasn't really
happy going to school so i asked my
parents i said yo can i take off a half
a semester really see if i can make this
thing a career and they said okay and
they let me do a half a semester off i
focus a lot on gaming and then the rest
was kind of history
out there in the public a lot for gaming
has uh meant a lot to me as far as like
you know pushing diversity in the space
and kind of encouraging other you know
black gamers like this is a career path
that you can chase
you don't really need a fancy computer
you don't need a lot of
gadgets there's a lot of expensive
things in reality i started with i mean
like a 50 inch tv in a garage with air
conditioning on the lowest of low
quality setups if you love gaming if you
love just creating content and overall
just like i said being a gamer
definitely a career path
[Music]
you